social robots are robots that are
intentionally designed to mimic cues
movements sounds whatever that people
automatically subconsciously associate
with states of mind
and this works really well
i first got really into this topic when
i bought a toy called a pleo it's a baby
dinosaur robot that came out in 2007.
so this is the pleo
the pleo is a very cool toy that i
initially bought because it has all
these cool motors and touch sensors and
an infrared camera in the snout and it
mimics lifelike behavior really well
and one of the things it has is a tilt
sensor so
it'll know what direction it's facing i
thought this was really cool and i would
show it off to my friends and
i would tell my friends to hold it up by
the tail because this is what happens
when you hold the plio up by the tail
[Music]
it mimics pain and distress
so i would show this off to my friends
and
some of my friends held it up for a
really long time and watched it squirm
and that started to make me
uncomfortable i realized i would ask
people to put it back down and say
that's enough
put him back down and then i would pet
the robot to make it stop crying
and that was really interesting because
i knew exactly how the robot worked and
i still felt compelled to comfort it
so that sparked a curiosity in me and
fast forward a few years i did a
workshop
with my friend honest gosselin at a
conference called lyft in geneva we took
five of these baby dinosaur robots we
gave them to five groups of people
we had each group name their robot and
play with it interact with it we had
them do a little fashion show with the
robots where they dressed them up in
pipe cleaners and construction paper
just so that we could
personify them a little and then after
about 45 minutes to an hour we unveiled
a hammer and a hatchet and a knife and
we told them to torture and kill the
robots
now this turned out to be pretty
dramatic we obviously wanted it to be
dramatic but it turned out to be more
dramatic than we expected it to be
we had initially thought okay
there's probably going to be a split of
people in the room some people are going
to say oh so what it's just a robot and
some people are going to have more of a
problem with the violence
and we wanted to ratchet up the violence
and see how the split in the room
changed and instead everyone just
absolutely refused to even hit the baby
dinosaur robots we finally had to
threaten to destroy all of the robots
unless someone took a hatchet to one of
them
and this poor guy volunteered and we all
stood in a circle around him
and he brought the hatchet down on the
on the robot's neck and people kind of
winced and looked away
and then there was this half-joking
half-serious moment of silence in the
room
for the fallen robot